going to the mound tonight it's lopey
for his fifth start of the year two on
two out
high fastball punched him out lopez
squeezes through white sox get ready to
face the 27 year old native of oklahoma
city oklahoma michael fulmer and two on
one down so here's abreu
jose over second base into center
stocks have taken the lead grondol to
third jose abreu's got a new streak
cooking and it's one nothing that's just
a great piece of hitting that's a guy
that just understands
what he's doing in the middle of this
lineup and what he has to do with run
number 41 driven in first and third here
with one out here is eloy jimenez
eloy
right field in the alleyway and here
comes at least one more run
rondale scores abreu gets a stop sign at
third and skids the brakes an rvi double
alloy jimenez two nothing trello rbi
number 34.
one more hit would be real nice here
second and third one out
and carnaziona fister reyes was playing
deep and he's not going to get there
edwin drives in another one it's three
nothing socks with just one out in the
first boy good teams do this right
back to back one out singles for the
white sox here in the second yasmani
grandall walked and scored in the first
on the ground to candelario
to second the turn is in time
tough way to turn two but the tigers did
it to keep it three-nothing chicago so
here is nomar mazara with runners at
first and second
and now two outs here in this third
inning three-nothing white tops
mazara left center field this is up the
alleyway rolling all the way to the
warning track of the wall
abreu's home
double makes it five nothing and a big
two out hit
this one just drifts on the outside part
of the plate he goes down and gets it
and then it's off to the races for eloy
that's going to be it for former it's
going to be the last one he's going to
throw in tonight's action
here's daniel norris in for michael
fulmer this is the number nine hitter
nick medigal
now the 3-1
little looper and that will be caught by
victor reyes
wow he laid out and stole a base hit
away from nick matagro
what a play by reyes he continues to
shine with the leather two out single
keeps the line moving here for jorge
bonifacio
lifted right-hand side mazara on the
move toward the line nomar in the corner
and that ball falls in the corner
and will bring home
the throw
and that is in time
oh the socks with a beautiful relay
cut down willy castro
somehow some way
one out walk has him at first and second
now and jose abreu who's two for two
with a run batted in will come up
jose tags at center field ray is going
back at the track at the wall it is gone
that's an eight spot with one out in the
fourth that'll teach you to break his
hit streak that's a 14th homer he's
driven in four tonight giving him 44.
what a year it's been it's now eight
nothing here in the fourth inning lead
off single here in the fifth that'll
bring up anderson who's three for three
how about a four hit dave for tim
anderson his fourth of the year to lead
the league and he missed a week and a
half and down to third goes madrigal at
first is mon kata so an rbi opportunity
for yasmani
how about another run grandau drives in
madrigal nine nothing first and second
with one out here is abreu
all that balls hammered
way out of here bring him home again
goodness gracious ride the wave with
jose abreu two three run homers in
consecutive innings by jose
sucks her up a dozen
in the fifth inning pieces are loaded
with nobody out here in the sixth inning
ground ball to shortstop they will get
one and they will not get two so tim
takes the rbi it is 13 nothing socks hey
first and third and luis robert now to
the plate as that ball's hit in the air
left field bonifacio on the move toward
the corner he makes the catch and luis
will get his rbi abreu scores
and it's 14 nothing
first and third two out and willie
castro
the batter with the shutout on the line
for the sox
bloop toward right field angle rushes in
and secures the shutout for ronaldo
lopez
and a dangerous sox offense tonight
this is one of those games that was put
away early by the offense a wonderful
performance by ronaldo lopez a special
performance by jose abreu as he drove in
seven this was quite a night